[Applause]
all right
well please stop we have a big show a
lot of news to get to I'm sure you know
the big story Joe Biden our president
went to Israel this week nothing to do
with the war just wanted a break from
the tension in
DC but I think this was his best week as
President Joe Biden this was
his I think so his finest
hour I mean and then gets his ass on a
plane it cut can't be easy he's not what
he's not a young man he remembers when
the Dead Sea was
alive he told the Wailing Wall to keep
it down no he's not a young man but uh
no he went there to give Israel an aid
package he's he's like the world's
Grandpa he can't visit without slipping
a little money you know
[Music]
just get some missiles don't tell
Grandma but uh then he came home he made
a great speech about Israel at the end
of it they caught this on camera
somebody yells clear and then somebody
goes that was great of course great uh
the bar for great in the Biden White
House is like if Hunter doesn't want in
with a heart
on just to put it in perspective I'm
just but here's the thing he wants to
give all this money to Ukraine and to
Israel uh but we has to come from
Congress and we don't have
one the the House of Representatives I'm
sure you've know this for the last 70
days remains paralyzed from the neck
up
uh the Republicans control the house
they want to elect this guy Jim Jordan
you know Jim Jordan he's a from Ohio
with former Jim teacher I call him Jim
Jim
Jordan and he's a
uh he he's what you call an
insurrectionist insurrectionist you know
he he's not really an indoor Republican
which is troubling to some of them
because he sends women running to the
other party
he's an election denier a conspiracy
theorist and a creep
uh or as Matt Gates calls him
dad
um
but see the problem with the Republicans
is they have just enough crazy
Republicans to keep a sane person from
getting the job and just an up sane to
keep the crazy people from getting the
job ironically they have a Mexican
standoff in the Republican
Party